today on the matt wahl show i am now a
children's author my book went on sale
yesterday and it's already making some
people very upset i'll explain why today
also joe biden gives a press conference
about the dreaded
super mega turbo omicron variant and
lauren bobert and ilhan omar attempt to
patch up their differences over a phone
call and it apparently doesn't go well
chris cuomo finds himself in another
scandal involving his brother and the
trial of kim potter who's the officer
who accidentally shot dante wright
begins most people on the both the left
and right seem to think she deserves
jail time i disagree and i'll explain
why and we'll take a look at a gender
studies master's thesis you might expect
it to be totally delusional and insane
and you're right but it's even worse
than you imagine all of that and more
today on the matte wall show
[Music]
well i am thrilled to uh once again talk
about an incredible app that everyone
who buys gas needs to know about it's
called get upside my listeners are
making up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas every time they fill up just
download the free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now
uh it's all upside with get upside
that's why it's it's an appropriately
named product use promo called walsh and
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that's up to 50 cents a
gallon cash back 25 cents a gallon from
there there on out
don't pay full price of the pump anymore
especially considering how full those
prices are at the moment get cash back
using get upside just download the app
for free use promo code walsh you get up
to 50 cents a gallon cash back on your
first tank some people who drive a lot
are making i've talked to people making
two to three hundred dollars 400 a month
in cash back
but whatever you make it's free money
that you're getting back to you so why
wouldn't you take advantage you can cash
out any time to your bank account paypal
or even get an e-gift card to amazon or
somewhere else just download the free
get upside app and use promo code walsh
to get up to 50 cents a gallon cash back
on your first tank that's code walsh
well first we saved abuela and then we
saved virginia and now we are saving the
children's book genre as any parent who
has ventured into the children's section
at barnes noble knows the category has
become totally flooded by left-wing
propaganda every other title on the
shelf is like anti-racist baby or i am
jazz or jacob's new dress or
charlie the unicorn has two mommies and
three daddies or whatever a good portion
of this agit prop has a has a racial
message
like anti-racist baby but most of it is
focused on gender and identity the first
and primary goal of the indoctrinators
is to induct children into the religion
of gender ideology
why is that so important well because as
i've long argued we are in the midst of
a war over truth itself these are not
scuffles around the edges of truth we're
not fighting over
the truth or falsehood of this or that
claim
the goal of the left fundamentally is to
relativize everything
relativize reality
he wants to be the god of his own life
his own universe
this is how he envisions freedom this is
what he means when he uses the word
freedom in the sense of being untethered
from any sort of objective defining or
definable force floating aimlessly
in in in some sort of ambiguous abyss
that's his that's his goal that's uh
that's freedom
and if this is the goal then there's no
better place to start than by
undermining biological reality freeing
oneself from biology and there's no
better place to start that project than
with children who already have a tenuous
grasp on reality and will believe pretty
much anything you tell them
children have no choice you know but to
rely on the adults around them to guide
them through the early stages of life
the young of many different species have
this need to one degree or another
degree or another and sometimes in the
lesser species this vulnerability of the
young and their reliance on
um
on
the older members of the species puts
them in danger you know rats for example
will sometimes eat their own young lions
and scorpions will do the same
humans have a more ideological version
of this
helpless children are devoured
by the leftist indoctrinators
the predator feeds upon the innocence of
the child exploits it
using that innocence to his own
advantage
this is going on everywhere especially
in the books and the shows and other
forms of entertainment made for kids
these days and for a long time
conservatives have essentially
surrendered this ground to the left
like it surrendered almost everything
else
allowing the left to turn children's
books into vehicles for this cult-like
brainwashing without offering any
response or alternative basically but
it's time for that to change which is
why uh as i told tucker carlson last
night when i announced the book i've
embraced my true calling as a children's
author cardigan and all
and uh written my first work of
children's literature which is johnny
the wall which i have right here
and um
now i'm not going to do a reading on the
show today originally i was going to do
that but we actually have a video coming
out later today where i read the book to
a group of preschoolers
and that should be released at some
point this afternoon or evening on my
youtube channel make sure you check that
out you don't want to miss it
so instead i'll give you just the brief
synopsis it's kind of difficult to
summarize because it's a lengthy story
of some 400 words across
30 cardboard pages
it took me
many months to write as you can imagine
many nights i spent hunched over my
typewriter um honing and crafting this
work of literature
but in brief if i can summarize
it's a story about a creative and
imaginative young child
like most young children creative and
imaginative he likes to play pretend and
one day he pretends to be a walrus as
you can see on the cover there um he
even has a wood spoons in his mouth like
tusks and and socks on his hands like
fins but unfortunately his mommy is the
confused and impressionable sort
and she learns from the internet that if
your child identifies as something then
he must actually be that thing
johnny's mommy thus spends the majority
of the story trying to you know raise
her child according to his walrus
self-identity she does her best to um to
you know give her trans walrus son the
sort of walrus life that she thinks he
wants and needs and at one point at the
darkest point in the novel
which yes i am calling it a novel even
if the pages are made of cardboard she
brings him to a purple-haired doctor who
recommends that he take medication and
undergo surgical procedures to complete
his walrus transition pretty brutal
procedure too
over time though
not to spoil the ending
johnny's mommy comes to understand that
just because a child pretends to be
something
that doesn't mean he actually is what
he's pretending to be
so this is a book in many ways about
self-acceptance
true self-acceptance we heard that that
phrase a lot but true self-acceptance
a mother's realization that her child
will only really be happy in his true
natural identity
we should encourage our kids to use
their imaginations
but what we should not do is create an
identity crisis within our kids
as so many parents have done these days
now my goal with this book which you can
buy now at
johnnythewalrus.com that's
johnnywalrus.com
was to create something that makes a
point about the madness of gender
ideology that a point that parents will
understand but also something that you
could actually read to your kids at the
same time
kids will engage with it as just a silly
sort of story about a boy pretending to
be a walrus adults will understand it on
a different level
but my hope also is that kids after they
hear this story
we'll come to understand phrases like
identifies as in a certain light
now i don't use the word transgenderism
in the book because i'm not going to
introduce that concept myself to the
kids but later on
when they do encounter these concepts
which they will
eventually at one point or another
hopefully their mind will make the
connection back to this story they can
say oh
this person is a boy who identifies as a
girl that's just like the boy who
identified as a walrus
they ought to understand it in that
framework in that context
because it is exactly that sort of thing
raising a boy as a girl is exactly as
absurd and grotesque and wrong
as raising a boy as a walrus
exactly the same
these are the connections that i want to
make with this book which you can now
buy at johnny johnnywalrus.com now i've
been accused of of making a mockery
of gender ideology with this book
treating it as a joke
as something totally ridiculous
and on that point my critics are correct
that's exactly what i'm doing i am not
only trying to make a point here for
adults on one level and kids on another
but i'm also openly making fun of the
whole idea that boys can be girls and
girls can be boys
we ought to make fun of that idea
it's the idea we're making fun of
now the kids themselves don't make fun
of them far from it they are victims
but the idea ought to be mocked
we ought to mock it because it is
patently insane and worthy of mockery
you know mockery is an important tool we
should use it more often i think on the
right
when something deserves to be mocked it
should be
when someone comes forward with an idea
that's completely insane and has no
basis in reality
if you do anything but mock it then you
are affirming it
if you if you in any way whatsoever take
the idea seriously even if you don't
agree with it if you sit down and say
well i don't really agree but let's talk
about this let's let's have this guy
let's have the conversation and
you've already affirmed it
so mockery yes that's exactly correct
i've also been accused of engaging in my
own form of indoctrination that's one
thing a lot i've got a lot of emails and
messages saying well aren't you you're
against indoctrination isn't this book
johnny the walrus
isn't this indoctrination
yes it is again my critics are correct
it is indoctrination i am i am also
doing indoctrination i am indoctrinating
kids with this book as i said i
literally read the book to a room of
preschoolers and indoctrinated them
proudly so
see i have nothing against
indoctrination per se what matters is
not that kids are being indoctrinated of
course they're being indoctrinated all
kids are
but what the issue is what precisely
they are being indoctrinated into
so i am indoctrinating kids
into reality
into truth
into common sense
into a into a sense of the world that is
grounded in truth that's exactly the
sort of indoctrination we ought to be
doing
finally my critics will say that i am
not a real children's author that this
is just a stunt or a gag
that my name does not belong in the
pantheon of great children's authors
alongside soos and doll and silverstein
that is one criticism i cannot agree
with or abide
this is my chosen identity now and i
have the cardigan to prove it
johnny the walrus is a legitimate
children's book and what's more it is a
work of literature and some would say
some would say that it's perhaps even
the finest american novel ever written
some would say that
i'll leave you to make that assessment
which you can do after you purchase the
book at johnnythewalrus.com please do it
soon though because amazon is uh i'm
almost certain they're going to ban this
thing any minute
so there is a certain urgency here also
it will be very very funny if we can get
this book to the top of the charts it's
already in the top 20 or 25 which is
funny but the top spot would be among
other things
um hilarious you have to admit we just
need the extra push to get it there
which you could provide by buying a copy
for yourself and your family members
family members especially your liberal
family members uh that would this would
make a great christmas gift for them
at johnnythewalrus.com but in any case
wherever it settles on the charts and
whether it gets banned or not
what i am saying to the left today is
that two can play at the children's book
game
i have my sweater on
i'm ready for war on this battlefield 2
with my friend johnny the walrus by my
side
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well thankfully i have again another
opportunity to talk about my favorite
subject which is um
refinancing mortgages okay this is the
realm that i kind of live in
and uh
if you are
living in a home right now uh did you
know that it can cost you less okay
you're paying more than you have to pay
you can lower your payment and save
thousands long-term you just have to
refinance to one of these incredibly low
mortgage rates and you should do it now
before they're gone these rates are
expected to rise in the new year you
cannot afford to miss out on this
money-saving opportunity especially with
how expensive everything is these days
here's a chance to save some money every
single month just takes a 10-minute call
to american financing america's home for
home loans you'll work with a
salary-based mortgage consultant someone
who will guide you through custom loan
options that can save you up to a
thousand dollars a month that's right a
thousand dollars a month is what you
could be saving you don't have to reset
your loan to get these kinds of savings
you can choose any term 10 years and
over because you shouldn't pay interest
for years that you don't need
pre-qualify for free at
866-569-4711 that's 866-569-4711
or visit
americanfinancing.net all right um
you know i uh i was saying yesterday
about talking about my thanksgiving
break and uh how my my wife was fat
shaming me and body shaping me on the
internet
um
there is something else that i was just
thinking about i feel kind of bad
because uh
before you know i think it was on
thanksgiving day before dinner but you
know we were sitting in the living room
and um
my mom told me that um she she couldn't
she was having trouble getting her vcr
to work
so she was telling me that she needed
help with her vcr
and she wanted to see if i could figure
it out
and the problem is that and she knows
this okay i mean she obviously knows
this i'm i'm a sarcastic a-hole i mean
hence this book
so you you just you can't come to me and
ask me to help you with your vcr without
me first making fun of it for about five
minutes i i it's a it's a i can't
control it's an impulse
what else there'll be a vcr
so she asked me to help fix the vcr and
i said you know unfortunately i would
but it's the year 2021 and i left my
time machine at home
and then i said i would but and you know
and afterwards maybe i could help fix
her printing press
maybe i could take a stab at repairing
her butter churn and i had this whole
routine about the vcr and then she just
gave up asking and i and i never fixed
it
so she's at home now
um with a with a broken vcr
what a terrible son i am i feel bad
about that um uh okay
let's go to
well we'll start with this joe biden
gave a press conference about here's
someone who knows something about vcrs
joe biden gave a press conference about
the the dreaded amicorn omicron what is
it is it um here's there's one he he
uses the phrase omni so i'm not even
sure if it's ami kron or uh or omnicron
i'm not sure what it is but it's the
super mega mega charge turbo deluxe
variant and here he is talking about it
the very day the world health
organization identified the new variant
i took immediate steps to restrict
travel from countries in southern africa
but while we had that travel
restrictions can slow the speed of
omnicron it cannot prevent it but here's
what it does
it gives us time it gives us time to
take more actions
to move quicker to make sure people
understand you have to get your vaccine
you have to get the shot you have to get
to get the booster if you're the sooner
or later we're going to see cases of
this new variant here in the united
states
we'll have to face this new threat just
so we face those that come before it
this variant is a cause for concern not
a cause for panic
we have the best vaccine in the world
the best medicines the best scientists
and we're learning more every single day
and will fight this variant with
scientific and
and knowledgeable actions and speed
not chaos and confusion
in the event hopefully unlikely that
updated vaccinations or boosters are
needed to respond to this new variant we
will accelerate their development and
deployment
with every available tool
i want to read
dr fauci believes we've heard we've
heard enough this is this is always this
is
right
this is always the process where first
they say
well it's uh it's not a cause it's don't
panic but it's a cause for concern
so we start there and then within a few
days they're saying uh yeah actually you
got to stay locked in your home and uh
if you go outside without a mask on
you're going to kill your grandparents
and your children
um so but but don't panic
be wearing look can we just say this
first of all wearing the mask around
everywhere
is a form of panic
so that that's what that is so when they
say well don't panic just wear your mask
everywhere what they're saying is don't
panic but panic
that's a panic
and there are there are people of course
as we know that have been
uh
in a in a literally a perpetual state of
panic from for
a year and a half almost two years now
a non-stop state of panic when you see
someone
walking down the street with a mask on
or and i've i saw it again the other day
not here in nashville but we were
traveling
i saw it again someone in their car this
is not over there are people still doing
this and they're going to continue to do
it forever it's a lifestyle now
uh but someone in in their car by
themselves with the mascot you know that
classic scene
but that is someone who has been in a is
in a total state of panic and has not
left that state and probably never will
i don't know how they've survived
just from a cardiovascular perspective i
don't know they haven't had all had
heart attacks by now
um
so of course they they do want you to
panic even though
the only thing that they should be
saying about omnicorn
is that um as far as we know it's just
it's nothing to worry about it's all the
information we have right now of course
information could always change and you
know anything could happen right
it could happen that tomorrow some
variant with a 50 fatality rate comes
along
probably won't but it could
happen we don't need to talk about could
especially when
when the question is how are people
living their lives
you can't live your life in response to
theories and goods and case scenarios
uh you have to live your life
so according to everything we know all
the information we have we played the
clip for you yesterday
of the doctor who first alerted people
to this variant
and she's the one saying it's nothing to
panic about panic about it's a it's
these are very mild symptoms
it's a cold
that's my
my word not hers but she said very mild
symptoms
these are cold like symptoms
that's if the president is going to say
anything about omnicorn that's all he
really needs to say
speaking of being in a perpetual state
of panic we know in new zealand
both in australia and new zealand
if there's even one case
of covid whether it's omnicorn or
anything else they shut everything down
and new zealand has been in a shutdown
for who knows how long they're now
starting to open things up a little bit
and the prime minister of new zealand
gave her own press conference yesterday
where she um
finally gave uh the citizens of her
country permission to go into their
friend's homes and even if they want
use the bathroom this is a great
privilege that this benevolent and
generous woman has bestowed upon her
citizens let's listen to that
and importantly because i know this is a
question many aucklanders have
you can now see family and friends again
in their homes
and use the bathroom inside
luxury
isn't that funny
it's hilarious
now there's nothing funny about it at
all and
politicians
should be
terrified
to speak to their citizens this way
the whole idea of a
of a politician
standing in front of a camera
and giving you permission to go to your
friend's house and use the bathroom
i would say treating you like a child
but
that's that's something something even
worse than that
because my children don't
my own children don't ask for permission
to go to the bathroom
i don't have to ask for permission for
that
so you are being more infantilized than
a child
um and politicians should be terrified
doing that
they should be terrified to speak to
their citizens that way
but they're not and that's this isn't
just in new zealand australia it's here
too
talking to us like we are idiots like we
are let look like we are children but
even but even but even dumber than that
treating us like literal babies
um
all across the west this is how
politicians talk to their citizens and
it was never supposed to be that way not
in our system anyway
all right speaking of politicians let's
move to this this is from the hill a
little bit of an update about a story we
talked about yesterday in the daily
cancellation representatives ilhan omar
and lauren bobert clashed in what would
both described as a tense phone call on
monday
after video surfaced of the uh
far-right lawmaker according to the hill
using that
qualification
making islamophobic remarks about her
colleague the two lawmakers issued
separate statements after the phone call
making clear that neither found the
conversation to be helpful in settling
their differences
this is from this is the statement we'll
play lauren bober talking about the
phone call but first here is ilhan omar
uh released her own statement about this
phone call
and she said today i graciously accepted
a call from representative lauren bobert
well stop right there and say that
gracious people never describe their
actions as gracious okay
um
it's it's a good hint that someone is
not gracious as if they have described
what they are doing as gracious
today i graciously accepted a phone call
from representative lauren bobert in the
hope of receiving a direct apology for
falsely claiming that she met me in an
elevator suggesting i was a terrorist
and for a history of anti-muslim hate
instead of apologizing for her for her
islamophobic comments and fabricated
lies representative bobert refused to
publicly acknowledge her hurtful and
dangerous comments
she instead doubled down on her rhetoric
and i decided to end the unproductive
call i believe in engaging with those we
disagree with respectfully but not when
that disagreement is rooted in outright
bigotry and hate
well we also know it's not gracious
because you said you you received the
phone call
um because you wanted to get you wanted
an apology
that's not gracious
i graciously accepted a phone call um
in the hopes that the other person
would bow before me and grovel and
apologize
i graciously
provided them the opportunity in the
platform to grovel before my feet
and this is apparently and both sides
say that this is you know they have
their own version of it but it ended
with uh with ilhan omar hanging up and
it didn't go well now
backing up for a second
like i said we we talked about this in
the daily cancellation
and who was i canceling i was canceling
lauren bobert
and not for the joke that she made she
made a joke at some kind of event in her
district she made a joke about ilhan
omar saying that she was worried being
in an elevator with omar but then she
realized that omar didn't have a
backpack on so she felt okay about it
and it's actually kind of a funny joke
and as i said it's a joke
that ilhan omar totally deserves and
brings on herself not because she's
muslim
but because she openly sympathizes with
terrorists
and she laughs about terrorist attacks
and she's dismissive of 9 11 the worst
terrorist attack on american soil in our
nation's history
famously she described it as some some
people did something
uh just like we could say with lauren
beauberg some woman told some joke
so because that's her attitude towards
terrorism
and she's openly sympathetic of
terrorists that's why she brings those
jokes on herself
and
even if she wasn't muslim
the jokes would still work
so that's all okay i'm fine with the
joke
um is it is it a respectful way to talk
about
your colleague no
but does ilhan omar one of the most vile
and vapid people in congress does she
deserve respect no
i i think all of us as adults we we have
to earn we want to be respected we have
to earn it
okay i believe that firmly
and that is doubly true for politicians
the whole respecting the office bit no
that's that's not our system we don't
live under a monarchy
if you want to be respected as a
politician as a public servant then you
got to earn that and if you don't
then you deserve to be disrespected
every day all the time
that's that's that's the healthy way to
treat politicians like that
so none of that is a problem the problem
is that uh and the reason she got
canceled yesterday is that beau bert up
did issue a public apology she tweeted
out a statement apologizing
and even worse she apologized to the
muslim community
which only confirms this idea
that uh that that she would that this
comment was made
as some kind of anti-muslim comment when
it wasn't this was a specific joke about
ilhanomar specifically because of her
specific actions
and words
so by apologizing and and you know
giving the outrage mob what it wants
there's there's no winning now
that's the thing you put yourself in an
unwinnable situation
and what you can't do
is grovel and apologize as beaubert has
already done
once you do that
you can't then backtrack and say i'm
gonna stand firm it's too late
the other thing you notice is and this
is why the this is why there's one of
the many reasons why apologizing is
always a bad idea
putting everything else aside it's not
going to work you're only doing it
you're not doing it because you're
actually you actually feel bad about it
um
no you're doing it because you you think
it's in your best interest it's
self-serving
and you think it's gonna call it's gonna
you know call the mob off
but it won't
because she publicly apologized and what
did ilhan omar do she demanded another
apology
and if she got that apology she'd ask
for another one
so here is uh bobert
talking about this and i think really
illustrating why there why why you put
yourself in an unwinnable a lose-lose
situation when you start apologizing
let's listen
hey everyone this is lauren with a quick
update on a phone call i had today with
squad member ilhan omar i had reached
out to her friday and three days later i
was able to connect with her on the
phone because i wanted to let her know
directly that i had reflected on my
previous remarks now as a strong
christian woman who values faith deeply
i never want anything i say to offend
someone's religion so i told her that
even after i put out a public statement
to that effect she said that she still
wanted a public apology because what i
had done wasn't good enough so i
reiterated to her what i had just said
she kept asking for a public apology so
i told ilhan omar that she should make a
public apology to the american people
for her anti-american anti-semitic
anti-police rhetoric she continued to
press and i continued to press back and
then representative omar hung up on me
rejecting an apology and hanging up on
someone is part of cancel culture 101 in
a pillar of the democrat party make no
mistake i will continue to fearlessly
put america first
never sympathizing with terrorists
i'm sorry it's kind of embarrassing now
for bobert it's too late for that
that's a strong courageous and i'm going
to apply
bipartisan fairs fair here you know you
don't describe your own actions as
gracious you don't you don't you also
don't describe your own actions as
fearless okay fearless people don't say
i fearlessly did this
um especially because it's too late for
that you already apologized so it's too
late to take a fearless stand
you may be exhausted with it now because
you realize that one apology means you
have to just apologize again
and so you're kind of backing away out
of exhaustion fine but that's not a
fearless stand the time to take a
fearless stand was before it's too late
now
you might get another opportunity in the
future but as far as this incident goes
you're already lost because you
apologized
and everything you do from here on the
best thing to do is just move on from it
making a phone call why even make the
phone call
what was the point of that
you you didn't want to continue to
grovel i i appreciate that so then why
talk on the phone all you can do now
does lauren bobert does she have a comms
team does she have a pr team at all
tell move on from this don't do any more
videos leave it alone
you lost this one because you apologized
it's over there's no way to flip it back
around
everything you do now just makes you
seem more sort of petty and childish
um
and she says and she's still saying she
says well i you know i wanted to let her
know that i reflected on my previous
comments you didn't reflect on it you
reacted
this is not reflection it's reaction
okay when you say something
and uh and and
and then you say it and that's it and
then there's a huge public reaction to
it
and outrage
and then you apologize that's not
because
you you reflected you didn't go off a
climb a mountain or something talk to
some guru up on a mountain about the
meaning of life and come back with with
your deep reflections okay you know you
didn't do that you didn't go off to the
to the beach and sit there and stare at
the sunset and think deeply about this
no
you panicked because people were upset
at you
and you reacted
reflection is exactly what
is needed and didn't happen here
and also as i said yesterday yesterday
and i i don't mean to harp on this but
it's it's so important and i'm so tired
of seeing this from conservatives
the reflection should happen
before
okay you're saying something in front of
an audience
you know you're on camera and if you
don't didn't know you're on camera then
then that's that's even dumber you have
to assume as a politician or anybody
talking into a microphone in front of an
audience you're on camera
and so you choose to offer this anecdote
this joke
you obviously know that it's edgy that
it's politically incorrect you know that
so reflect ahead of time
i'm not saying don't say it i'm saying
reflect ahead of time about what the
reaction is going to be and how you are
going to respond when that inevitable
reaction happens
so it's too late um move on learn from
it
come back next time and do better
that would be my advice
if i was ever hired by a politician to
be their communications director which
will never happen
but um that's the right thing okay
and that's and that's in general last
point i'll make about this
when it comes to public outrage
and if i had a pr firm
uh my advice would be very simple my job
would be very easy
because when it comes to public outrage
there are there are two possible courses
of action
and only two
one is to say nothing at all and that's
that's always
that's always a valid option
saying nothing is always a valid option
because because no one is going to
remember this
there are there's a there are a million
things happening every single day we are
bombarded by information
there's always a new controversy there's
always something new trending
okay you're trending on twitter because
people are mad at you
even at the moment that you're trending
there are 50 other things trending
and the most you'll ever trend is for
like 12 hours and then it goes away
so ignoring it completely is definitely
an option
or if you're not going to do that
then double down and refuse to apologize
but do it in a smart way have a plan in
place know exactly what you're doing
that's also enough those are the two
that's that's it
um and for most people you know the best
option a lot of the time especially if
you're not a political person
you know um the best option is is the
first one which is to say nothing
okay
next uh here's another pr crisis from
cnbc it says cnn host chris cuomo used
his sources in the media world to seek
information on women who accused his
brother andrew cuomo then the governor
of new york of sexual harassment
according to documents released monday
by the new york attorney general's
office um
while chris cuomo has previously
acknowledged devising his brother and
his team on the response to the scandals
the records show that his role in
helping the then governor was much
larger and more intimate
than previously known
chris cuomo was actively in touch with
melissa derosa
who was the then governor's top aide
about incoming media reports of that
detailed alleged sexual harassment by
andrew cuomo he also lobbied to help the
governor's office as it sought to
weather the storm
and he dictated statements for the then
governor to use
apparently he tweeted to derose in one
message or rather texted her
please help please let me help with the
prep
and then another point um
in reference to anna ruch
who accused uh cuomo of making an
unwanted advance he said i have a lead
on the wedding girl
okay so he's using his sources to find
out information about these women he's
he's helped him to craft statements he's
doing all of this
and he's doing all of this while he's
ostensibly i don't know what he can even
consider himself a journalist
can hardly say without laughing
here's what i'll say about this
first of all i can't stand chris cuomo
i've got no love for chris cuomo
if he gets fired fine that's fine with
me
he deserves to be fired for a million
different reasons
with all that said
this particular scandal
doesn't
bother me all that much like i i this
this is
of all the reasons to be upset at chris
cuomo generally being a dishonest hack
is the main reason and that's why i
don't like him
and that's why he deserves to be fired
i'll be fine if he is
even though as we as we've covered he's
just going to be replaced by somebody
worse but even so as far as this goes
it's just it's not the kind of thing
that makes me very upset and i'll tell
you why i'm not defending it ethically
i'm just saying that you know helping
out a family member
even by potentially unethical means
i don't i'm i'm not saying it's it's the
objectively morally correct path
but um
i understand it you know i i understand
when someone
pulls strings to help help their brother
out help their sister out
if if it were me you know if my brother
was caught up in some kind of thing
and there there was something i could do
behind the scenes to help him out i'd
probably do it
um
doesn't make it right but
you know i'm a firm believer in putting
family first
so i guess my point is of all the
reasons to dislike cuomo
i would put this near the bottom of the
list
so it's very similar to his brother
who was getting all the the grief and
all the flack for the sexual harassment
claims
meanwhile he's got this other issue of
where he killed elderly people
and so i'm not going to defend him on
the sexual harassment claims but what i
am going to say is uh
really we we should be focusing on this
thing over here which is much much worse
and with chris cuomo he he doesn't have
anything quite as bad as murdering
elderly people i mean most people have
never done that but um
he does have sins i think that are worse
than you know trying to help his brother
out
okay next uh three trials are starting
this week justice millett jizlane
maxwell i still have not figured out how
to pronounce her first name where to go
with jizz lane jizzling maxwell and kim
potter potter was the officer who
accidentally shot dante wright in
minneapolis during a traffic stop she
was trying to arrest him he fought her
she meant to reach for her taser but she
pulled her gun instead just to give you
an idea of how this trial is being
covered and to kind of review some of
the facts of the case here's the local
nbc affiliate talking about and and this
is
talking about the case and specifically
dante wright's family
who had a press conference yesterday and
and what they're saying about this
we are expecting justice we are not
asking for it one day before jury
selection begins in the manslaughter
trial of kim potter dozens of community
leaders and families of those killed at
the hands of law enforcement stood in
solidarity with donte wright's mother
katie thank everybody for the support
back on april 11 wright a 20 year old
black man was pulled over by brooklyn
center police officers due to expired
tags officer kim potter pulled out her
gun and shot wright once in the chest as
seen in body camera footage potter later
said she meant to pull out her taser
instead of her gun potter now faces
first and second degree manslaughter
charges defense attorneys argue the
shooting was an accident dante wright
was a student of mine at edison high
school george floyd's girlfriend
courtney ross recalled the day she first
heard of wright's death by the time i
got home
i found out that that man
that young man
was dante wright
mind you
dante's murder took place
during the international trial
of my man george floyd
um okay so there's there's
the trial dante right what his family is
saying
and we get the picture
as always
the necessary picture of dante wright
you know sitting there holding a child
um
looking very very innocent
what we should remember is that dante
wright
the way the media reports it is that
dante wright was stopped for a traffic
violation
and then i think originally the story it
was some something it's always bogus
almost all the details you hear about
these high profile police shootings
the the initial details are almost
always completely bogus not even based
on reality but but totally bogus so i
think originally we heard something
about
he was pulled over for an air freshener
so the original story was that he was
not only pulled over for it but but shot
and executed for having an air freshener
in his car that was the story that made
it made its uh and as we know the saying
you know the lie mixed all the way
around the world before the truth can
get its pants on and so that was the lie
in that case while the truth is
struggling to get its pants on and get
out there the lie was that he was
executed
in cold blood
for having a little uh you know little
christmas tree
air freshener hanging on his on his
windshield
on his rear view mirror
that was not true at all
he was pulled over for a traffic
violation but then it then they
discovered that he had an open
warrant for his arrest
and so that's why they tried to arrest
him not for a traffic violation
but because he had an open warrant for
his arrest and that's what you do with
someone when they have an open warrant
for their arrest why did he have an open
warrant for his arrest well he had it in
connection
with an incident where he allegedly
pointed a gun at a woman
and robbed her attempted to rob her
he also choked her and
according to the victim stuck his hand
down her shirt looking for a wad of cash
which is sexual assault of course so he
sexually assaulted a woman pointed a gun
at her and tried to rob her
that's why
that's the crime that
that lays the bottom there of that of
that arrest warrant
so what are they supposed to do
they pull someone over for a traffic
violation find out they have an arrest
warrant this is someone who's committed
armed robbery is the police are the
police supposed to say well hey uh
there's a a warrant for you're an arrest
you're a dangerous person but
you know we pulled you over for
something else so we're gonna let this
one slide okay
is that that what you think they should
do
well yeah that that's actually precisely
what the defunder police crowd would
prefer
they'd prefer to let dante wright go and
victimize another woman
this continues that trend
um that pattern
which is certainly not a coincidence
it goes far beyond a coincidence when
you have this pattern where
almost all of the martyrs for blm
especially in the last couple of years
not only are violent criminals but in
almost every case specifically they
target women
women are the targets of their of their
violence and that was the case for dante
wright so that's why they tried to
arrest him
he fought back
and they tried to tase him to bring him
in
and she she reached for the gun and shot
him instead
now we know that that happened we know
it was a mistake because she says on
camera she says basically says on camera
that it was a mistake and she didn't
mean to do it
legally
i don't know you know i don't like her
chances in court i think she's probably
going to go to jail
um so we'll see
but if it were up to me if i was on that
jury
would i send this woman to jail no i
would not
i wouldn't send her to jail
i look at this i put this in a similar
in a similar category to something like
a medical error you know a mistake that
that now there can be
medical errors that are made there can
be that are really malpractice
or a doctor or surgeon is being reckless
and if that happens then you have to
litigate it
but there are also hundreds of people or
more who die every year you know in
surgeries and that sort of thing from
medical errors that where nothing
reckless has happened it's just that
this is a life or death situation
life is hanging in the balance
and sometimes it can go the wrong way
and it's a terrible mistake but doesn't
mean you put someone in prison for it
so
the point is
when you are a wanted
an alleged armed robber
and the police are trying to bring you
in
and they're trying to use peaceful means
to do it
and you start fighting them physically
if a mistake happens in the in the
process of that occurring where you are
physically fighting the cops
as a wanted person
a violent felon
if a mistake happened an error happens i
put that on you
you could have avoided that easily
you deserve to go to jail that's what
should happen to you
you don't have a right to to resist and
run away
you rob you pointed a gun at a woman and
robbed her
you need to face the music you need to
go to so
if you fight back because you don't want
to face up to what you did
then you are taking your life into your
hands
you are putting yourself in a position
where really bad things can happen
like a mistake
and so i put it i put the onus on you
um
that's how i would see it on a jury
that's what i would argue but i have no
confidence the confidence that the jury
here will argue the same
let's get now to our comment section
right man this cardigan is getting hot i
don't know if i don't know if this
children's author deals for me if i have
to wear the cardigan then again no one
had told me i had to wear the cardigan i
just decided that that has to be the
uniform
um by the way if you go to dailywire.com
shop right now and head to my merch
store my my swag shack which is what i'm
calling it now apologies in advance but
that is what i'm going to call it
there's nothing you can do about it if
you head to my swag shack you'll you'll
find um and we'll show you this on the
screen but you'll find all of the great
merch that i've already shown you as
well as a whole new section a selection
of johnny walrus merchandise uh such as
a johnny the walrus shirt there's a
sticker here with a
a protester with a sign that says he him
walrus which is the preferred walrus
pronouns
um is this sort of just shameless
capitalistic exploitation in a way with
the merchandise yeah absolutely
and i want to be clear also that none of
the merch store money goes to charity it
it lines my pockets and the daily wire
um
marketing is not going to like this
pitch i don't even know if this will
make it on there
and i'm partially kidding of course when
you when you buy merchandise you're
supporting the mission the fight in a
very real way but mostly you're getting
some great memes to wear you can wear
our memes with pride and they are our
memes right
we have a lot of memes on the show and
uh most of them were a team effort
with with between me and you and the
audience and the team here at delaware
sweet baby gang of course is the prime
example
that's why you can't just blame me for
that that was our collective brainchild
some it was the the hideous monstrosity
that arose
out of our collectively dark and
depraved mind so that's a lot of what
you find there at the merch store uh or
rather the uh swag shack
william roby says
matt
what are the good jim carrey movies and
why
um yeah that's a good question i i said
that the truman show was his second to
last good movie maybe i should have said
third to last arguably
because i had
in mind the eternal sunshine of the
spotless mind which i haven't seen in
many years but i thought it was quite
effective when i did see it it's an
interesting movie
it kind of captured a failed
relationship really well maybe had some
interesting things to say about the
nature of memory and relationships and
so on um so i'd put that
and then there's also me myself and
irene which came in between truman show
and eternal sunshine and that was
serviceable so maybe you'll give them
that
but the point is that jim carrey you
want to talk about someone that's been
on a cold streak as an actor
um
maybe robert de niro gives jim carrey a
run for his money in al pacino
those three guys
putting out hit after hit
the 90s that was jim carrey's decade
everything you put out
and then he gets into 2000s and put out
almost nothing but garbage
all right let's see what else we got
here
um
let's see leah says no matt plants are
not sentient and you know that you're
not stupid stop acting like vegans are
so stupid for literally just being kind
animals yes you absolutely are the
[ __ ]
i truly enjoy watching your show but i
strongly disagree with you when it comes
to animals it's really sad that you
think so little of them that you think
it's completely fine to exploit and kill
them unnecessarily anyway i continue to
watch your content and stay subscribed
because i connect to many of you of your
other viewpoints and at least you don't
speak about your barbaric views on
animal rights too often well don't tempt
me leah because now you're just
ensuring that i will talk about it more
um
no first of all it's not about thinking
less of animals that's not i do think
less of animals as compared to people i
think they are lesser species than the
human species we've talked about why and
in fact you do agree with me on that
even if you claim that you don't
um as i've as i've pointed out you know
if you see a dead person on the side of
the road you're going to react very
differently than if you see a dead
squirrel and why is that because you
care more about the person which is good
you should
my only point about the about the the
plant life is that
okay i'm engaging in this hierarchy of
biological life i openly admit that i am
i think it's a rational and logical
thing to do i also think it's it's
totally rational and logical to to
prefer your own species over another one
um there's something kind of despairing
and suicidal about the people who prefer
other species to their
own but my point is you're doing the
same
because plant life we call it is life
isn't it
trees
lettuce
for everything in a salad
that's it's you look you look down at a
salad you see a salad i see um i see a
mass
genocide
with
with ranch dressing on top of it okay
because that that is also life and you
have determined that that life is less
valuable less important
than the life of say a chicken
so you're doing this hierarchy thing
and uh and so am i i don't see how
you're any better so now it's really
it's not that i have a hierarchy and you
don't it's that we have competing
hierarchies now so we can have that
conversation
all right what else we got here
um
another one says matt love the show want
to say that first my question is how do
you justify wanting to create culture
and change elections and bash the left
for doing so i don't mind the dw doing
so since you're correct however there
does seem to be a bit of a double
standard from you
whether justified or not not for me to
decide personally i'm more curious
whether you're where you're coming from
rather than
a gotcha moment have a good day y'all
anyone else have thoughts i'd love to
hear those
well first of all i feel like i have to
ban you for this for the show from the
show for challenging me but then being
so nice and polite about it which means
i don't get to be angry in response so
you've you've taken that away from me
and for that you're banned
um as far as your question
yeah i don't
it's just like what i said about
indoctrination
and i and i understand where the
confusion comes from
because a lot of people on the right
will say things like and they're and
it's just kind of a an intellectual
laziness or they're being lazy in the
way they speak
um
they'll say things like well we
we're against indoctrination of kids
and all that kind of thing
no it's not that the problem is not the
kids are being indoctrinated it's what
they're being indoctrinated into
on and when it comes to creating culture
i don't have a problem with the idea of
creating culture
it's
culture is good
we should
have a culture
my issue is the kind of culture that is
being created
and in fact on the left the kind of
culture they're creating is not even
really
a culture it's more of an anti-culture
it's like the apps it's a it's a vacuum
it's the it's a void it's the absence of
culture
and so what i think we need to do on the
right is create
culture real culture a good culture
um
an edifying culture a culture that
directs people towards
fulfillment and and their own well-being
and the common good that sort of thing
so hopefully that clears it up although
you're still bad from the show well i'm
not sure if i mentioned it yet but uh i
do have a kid's book out and um this is
this is the part where we do the dw
promo and it's uh just so happens to be
my book that we're promoting so once
again i get to tell you about johnny the
wall ridge is on sale right now
at
johnnythewalrus.com i will tell you that
i've i've already seen
the the action has started on twitter of
the left calling for amazon to ban this
book and um i don't have a lot of
confidence
that it won't get banned even though
it's a it's a lovely and a wonderful
book with i think a great message about
this young boy who um
has this identity of being a trans
walrus foisted upon him by his confused
mother but at the end they see the light
so it's a happy ending
um
but
it there's a good chance this thing's
going to get banned and that's a serious
issue so
go and buy the book right now
johnnythewalrus.com if we get it all the
way to the top of the charts it makes it
harder for them to ban it and if they do
it's more visible when they do which it
ought to be so
johnnythewalrus.com go there now buy the
book
[Music]
all right
for our cancellation today we turn our
attention to a gender studies master's
thesis composed by a student at the
university of wisconsin milwaukee
jonathan k is an editor at quillette and
he first brought attention to this on
his twitter page
the document had been available on the
university's website but has since been
put under embargo whatever that's
supposed to mean what it actually means
is that the university is embarrassed
that the public took note of this and so
they took it out of the public viewing
for that reason
all i really need to do is read the
first part of the introduction to this
thesis no other commentary is necessary
though i will offer some anyway so here
it is it's a little lengthy but it's
worth your time so
sit back and enjoy here it is
and this is all totally real by the way
i assure you
as a white first generation college
graduate who attended a mid-sized
private university my identities and
experiences inspired this study
my whiteness offers a level of inherent
violence to this study because of the
history of privilege and structural and
overt acts of harm my ancestors have
contributed to society this echoes my
experience in identifying as an
anti-racist racist who as a white person
spelled with an ex instead of an o a a
persistent
who as a white person
is inherently racist but applies and is
accountable to anti-racism in my life
through activist educator and researcher
capacities
white supremacy is frequently
misunderstood as only pertaining to
overt or explicit acts of violence like
neo-nazis or the ku klux klan however
white supremacy in the context of this
study centers the relationship between
historical and unconscious bias that
benefits whiteness through its
structures policies culture and
experiences over non-white individuals
therefore it is irresponsible for me to
be to begin this study without
acknowledging the privileges that i am
afforded in conducting this study as a
white individual but also the
contribution that i make to violence
like white supremacy in the in the
academy violence and university shows up
in different ways
than what may be explicitly produced
violence in the context of this study
includes interpersonal violence like
slurs and ignorance politics that
disproportionately have a negative
impact on marginalized identities or
bodies
the hierarchical misuse of
administrative power that make change
seem impossible and the lack of
understanding and support given to the
marginalized university community
and that's just the first few sentences
of the introduction
it's good that they took the whole
document off the website i don't know if
you could read much more of that or hear
much more of it without slipping
irretrievably into insanity
so let's go through this somewhat
haphazardly and make uh
four points in no particular order
first
bookmark this podcast and remember that
segment and come back to it this segment
in fact that we're in right now
and come back to it next time somebody
demands that you define critical race
theory because what you just heard
is critical race theory it's hard to
define because it's a jumbled
unintelligible mess
it's like being asked to describe in
precise terms the contents of a of a
porta potty now you may not be able to
break it all down in specific detail but
what you can say is that whatever is in
there it's a whole bunch of
for critical race theory the particulars
are intentionally hard to discern and
also irrelevant whatever finer
distinction it draws we know that it
teaches that white people are inherently
racist
that all non-white people are victims of
systemic racism that all white people
are beneficiaries of systemic privilege
and that white people all bear guilt
because of this and that also because of
this they cannot be the victims of
racism
even if a black man beats a white man
unconscious and spits on his lifeless
body
still that is not racism and arguably
it's not even violence
nothing can be racism against the white
man that's what crt teaches as we just
heard
second
notice how
will
and agency are removed from the equation
according to the crt vision of life
all of the fault lies with systems and
institutions and policies and the past
whites inherit their guilt
uh this way and non-whites inherit their
victimization in the same way nobody
does anything nobody's responsible for
anything we're all helpless dried up
little leaves floating on the wind
the author even says that ignorance is
violence
meaning that you can be guilty of
violence simply for not knowing
something
no willful action is taken on your part
you simply did not encounter certain
information and that makes you violent
again there's no agency there's no
choice there's no will
third we see that crt and leftism as a
whole
are a religion
but of course religion isn't bad in and
of itself so i'm always kind of
uncomfortable using religion in this
kind of pejorative way oh it's just a
religion i have a religion i'm religious
the problem isn't that it's a religion
the problem is that it's a false
religion
and you could tell a false religion
because almost everything it says can
only be understood within the context of
itself
everything is in insular right in a
false religion
or in a cult like scientology or
something
it has no insight or wisdom to offer
people who do not subscribe to it you
have to be a believer to see the value
or even meaning in any of this
so it's as i said it's like scientology
you know they they they indoctrinate you
into it little by little and there are a
lot of reasons for that one of the
reasons is that if you just dove into
scientology and they put you all the way
up at level seven or whatever the levels
are and they put you there right away
nothing that you're hearing would make
any sense to you
because you have to be brought into it
slowly and slowly until you kind of
adopt the logic which is an illogic of
this whole system
but from the outside it's completely
ridiculous
and has nothing of value to offer
anybody
um christianity which is not a false
religion is not like that christianity
has
um
has
wisdom you know even if you're not
religious even if you don't believe in
christianity you can and many people
have pick up pick up the gospels and
read them and you'll find
much wisdom and insight into the human
condition that you don't need to be a
christian to understand or even believe
so that's the difference
and finally i think i said there were
four things so the fourth thing is that
uh this is what you get at college okay
i don't need to elaborate on that very
much i have many times in the past this
is college so if you if you're a parent
and you're thinking about sending your
kid to college and plunging yourself or
your child into decades of debt
this is what you're paying for to turn
your kid into that
and that is why we must say the person
who wrote that thesis is canceled and
gender studies programs are canceled and
the university of wisconsin-milwaukee is
cancelled and uh really the whole
university system i think in the end is
cancelled and we'll leave it there
remember again johnnywalrus.com pick up
the book let's get it to the top of
amazon and we got to do it we got to do
it now before it uh it's uh before it's
banned so go right now the show is over
go to johnnywalrus.com pick up a book
pick up 10 books give them to all your
family members and i'll talk to you
tomorrow uh godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical directors austin
stevens production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 21.
today on the ben shapiro show chris
cuomo from cnn is outed as a key figure
in his brother's defense despite the
fact that he works at cnn that's today
on the bench bureau shall give it a
listen